another thing dr bright is not allowed  to do at the foundation dr bright is not  allowed to go to fan conventions let  alone use them as recruitment drives  especially not at furry conventions  we're fully aware that due to the  dangerous nature of the work staff turn  around at the scp foundation is much  higher than your typical non-profit  organization that does not however mean  we need to stoop to hiring random people  at conventions to work with us in order  to make up the numbers we lose and jack  we swear to the 05 council if you  convince one more group of furries to  download mellow some kind of dating  service we warn you the consequences  will be  severe